*Windows 7 Boot Noise*
*Knocking on door*
*Rock music plays*
*Vlog
Hey, welcome.
My name is Pewdiepie.
We're going to Pax.
Excellent.
Come on! This is for Sweden!
Say "Hi", everyone!
"Hi, everyone!"
What the fuck Ken
(RESIDENT EVIL BIOHAZARD)
WHAT THE FUCK IS THAT?!
OH SHIT!
OH WHAT THE FUCK?!
HEY!
THAT'S MY FUCKING KNEE!
(Poods back at it again...)
(Here we have a rare species of human called "Poods", in his natural habitat.)
Now, we're going to the convention -- no, wait. We're not.
We're going to the signing.
Oh, yeah. Jack is here.
(Poods does hate face)
It's at the West en-
Come- oh wait, I can't tell you to come watch because
it's already done ---- What are you doing?
Jack. Stop.
Pewds: Nothing.
Alright.
(Kwebbelkop waving in the background)
I'm very happy.
Michael : You enjoy the Pax, yeah?
I'm - I'm really enjoying the Pax.
(RARE SCENE OF TWO RARE SPECIES FIGHTING TO THE DEATH)
(Jack picks up I.D Card)
Pewds: THAT'S MINE YOU BIATCH!
(Jack does cute face)
*crowd cheering*
WOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
YYYEEEAAAAAAAAAHHHH!!!
(Hormones Intensifies)
from the crowd: Senpai!
Hey.
(POODS, I'M TELLING MARZIA!)
Jack: You getting some good shots Micheal? Micheal: Huh? Jack: Are you getting some good shots? Micheal: Yeah
Jack: Am I ready for my close up?
Michael: How is he, how is he? Tell me more.
It's good. Micheal's such a cutie.
Look at him behind the camera.
Felix says "Come back here. Cut all that."
"Cut everything. Cut everything."
We're taking over the vlog now, bitches.
Wazzup?
Uh, Green Pewdiepie. (Green Mario)
Uh, subscribe to Markiplier.
What is happening there?
Stop stealing my vlog!
Get out of my vlog!
Welcome.
Welcome, welcome.
It's a new day.
It's a new start.
Hope you're enjoying  this vlog that has nothing to do with me...so far.
We're gonna --- I don't know where you filmed, Michael.
Micheal: I filmed you. What are we doing today?
No. I meant like
the other days.
Okay, whatever.
Surprise me.
I'm gonna do a lie detector test.
I'm scared.
Michael: It's gonna be lit!
Don't say that.
(Here we have a wild PJ, about to be cooked.)
(POODS HOLDING TWO LIGHTSABERS)
PJ: Waa! Holy shit!
*FANFICS INCOMING!*
I can't.
Can we stop?
(Awkward Poods is Awkward)
CinnamonToastKen.
My mortal enemy.
It looks like you're, uh, wrapped up
in a tight situation. (No pun intended)
Alright.
So, Ken. I'm gonna ask you some questions.
You better not be lying.
If you lie,
you will get pied.
But, if you tell the truth,
you get to pie me. (yeah baby)
Do you have a secret crush...
...on another youtuber?
No.
That's a lie!
What?
Ken, you love me!
No, no!
I knew it!
Aww, that's real nice.
It's not true!
It's real --- Now, the truth finally comes out here on the show.
Now,
Jacksepticeye...
is about to get poodiepie'd.
Jack: I learned something about myself today.
Pewds: You look so crazy!
Oh my God!
You look insane.
Michael, let me see myself!
Okay.
So now,
Uhm, I'm going to meet up with some Make A Wish people.
And then, we do the panel.
and then, it'll be great! Awesome.
How's it going?
You're geared out. That's awesome!
Nice to meet you.
*Static*
So, I have the channel now.
It's mine
Sorry, Felix. I took it over. (Jack is Dylan CONFIRMED)
We're walking around Pax, still.
I'm much better at vlogging than Felix, anyway.
He sucks at it.
He never -- He never interacts with ----- See?
Somebody already said hi.
Hi~!
See? They didn't say "Hi, Felix!", didn't they?
No. They said, "Hi, Jack!"
Suck it.
Welcome to the vlog again.
This is the stage.
Of course, every -- all of my fans came.
I'm excited!
Yeah~!
Yes, I'm excited. Yeah!
Happiness!
He's an asshole! I hate him.
He keeps punching me punching me all the time.
Irish pussy!
Bitch!
(You okay Mark?)
Announcer: CinnamonToastKen
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!
AAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHH ----ACK!
Emma: Netflix and chill!
Felix: Yes!
Ken: 3, 2, 1, go
Mark: Childbirth
Giving birth
*cheering*
Jack: Michael Jackson
Emma: Frozen
Crowd:  Is that Marina Joyce? Marina  Joyce? Mark: Oh yeah, yeah! Pewds: It's Marina Joyce.  Crowd:AHHHHHH!
(Dance battle between Blossom and Buttercup)
Jack: U WOT M8
*Raging Hormones Intesifies*
Hey, that was so fun!
Look at all these people!
Beautiful people!
It's awesome.
This is really cool I really enjoyed it.
The question part was, uh, so good.
It was really useful.
Hope you like it
It was great!
So,
this is Pax.
I had a lot of fun.
I want to give a huge shout out to all the cool people --- I don't know why I shout out
This doesn't make any fucking sense.
Uh, everyone is really cool.
I had a lot of fun because
I got to meet, uh, friends and shit.
I know. I have friends. It's weird right?
Pax was great.
They did a great job.
Great convention.
They ... they made sure we had fun.
Now, I'm going back to this group of people.
Fucking assholes.
I don't really like them.
I got a pimple.
Really brewing up there.
It was really fun. I hope you enjoy the vlog.
If you did, leave a like.
Subscribe to become a bro if you haven't.
Let me know if you want more vlogs.
I always appreciate the feedback.
And
and BROFIST.
Piano music plays (stay till end of video for extra)
This is scary!
I'm not a bale of hay
(mumbling for the rest of the video)
Subtitles by: Harambe, Jc Don, JOHN CEEENNAA, and Daniel Gor.
GET PEWDIEPIE'D (PAX VLOG 2016)